THE PLAYERS ARE MAKING THEIR
WAY IN THAT DIRECTION.
IT WAS A SEVEN POINT WHEN OVER
THE UTAH JAZZ.
LET'S CHECK IN WITH DANTE
MARCHITELLI .
>> THEY WERE DOWN BY 10 IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER.
WHAT DID YOU GUYS DO TO COME
BACK AND WIN THE GAME?
>> WE FOUGHT.
I SHOUT OUT TO R.J.
HAMPTON.
I SET OUT TO  MO BAMBA.
WE HAD TO GET THE WIN.
A SHOUT TO THE MAGIC.
>> Reporter: EVENTS AND BIG
SHOTS.
HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO GET IT
GOING?
>> EVERYONE FOUGHT BACK.
I SET OUT TO R.J.
HAMPTON.
GARRY HARRIS  GOT THE BALL.
R.J.
HAMPTON HIT A THREE.
>> Reporter: WHAT DID HE SHOW
YOU?
>> IT IS THE DEFINITION OF
BEING READY.
HE STATED READY.
A SHOUT OUT TO R.J.
HAMPTON.
HE CAME IN READY.
HE HELPED US GET THE WIN.
>> Reporter: DONOVAN MITCHELL
TRIED TO ASSERT HIMSELF AT THE
END.
>> R.J.
HAMPTON STEPPED UP
DEFENSIVELY.
HE AND GARRY HARRIS . THEY WERE
LOCKED IN DEFENSIVELY.
>> Reporter: YOU FELT THE
GROUND.
A VERY GOOD CROWDED.
>> I SET OUT TO ALL OF THE
MAGIC FANS.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE BEST START.
I KNOW THE ARENA IS PACKED.
>> Reporter: IT IS COMING WITH
PERFORMANCES LIKE THIS.
I KNOW YOU HEARD THE MVP
CHANCE.
>> I DO NOT FEEL LIKE I
DESERVED IT.
>> Reporter: YOU DID IT
TONIGHT.
I KNOW YOU ENJOYED IT.
THERE WAS COLE ANTHONY WITH THE
BIG FOUR FORMANTS . THE MAGIC
HAVE THE WIN.
WE ARE AT AMWAY CENTER.
>> David: NEVER DULL